Marvel's midnight Sons is the new game
from for axis games the studio behind
civilization and the past three XCOM
titles midnight Suns is far from a
superhero reskin of XCOM however as it's
got a card based combat system and a
more substantial focus on role play
here's everything you need to know about
Marvel's midnight Suns the story in
Midnight Suns is based Loosely on the
90s comic book series rise of the
midnight Suns a crossover event that
paired up the Avengers with more
Supernatural and Magic based characters
to stop a demonic threat since the story
revolves around mystical threats the
roster includes characters who
specialize in supernatural abilities
like Doctor Strange Ghost Rider magic
and blade those characters are joined by
Avenger Mainstays like Captain America
Captain Marvel Iron Man and Wolverine at
launch there'll be 13 playable
characters with four more coming as DLC
but one of those 13 is your own player
character that character called the
Hunter is customizable in everything
from their appearance to their power set
and for axis says it worked closely with
Marvel to develop them the hunter has a
really cool Marvel tie-in too they are
the child of Lilith mother of demons
conveniently the main antagonist of the
game Lilith and her horde have joined
forces with Hydra and it's up to the
hunter to lead a team of Marvel heroes
to defeat them Marvel's midnight Sun's
combat will be turn-based similar to
XCOM 2 and XCOM Chimera Squad but with a
major twist instead of set abilities
Your Heroes will each have a deck of
ability cards that get shuffled together
when you bring three of them into combat
those cards range from basic attacks to
special skills allowing you to buff
other heroes or toss enemies around the
battlefield the cards can also be
customized with variations to suit your
playstyle in XCOM each of your soldiers
has a set of abilities they're able to
use but no guarantee that the ability
will hit this element of Random could be
thrilling a soldier hitting a shot they
had very little chance to hit for
example or disappointing like completely
whiffing a shot that had a 95 chance to
hit and believe me it's happened for the
first year of midnight Sun's development
the team at faraxis tried adding these
roles of the virtual dice to the game
and in their words they just didn't work
after experimenting with ways to
incorporate elements of Randomness into
the game they landed on a deck building
system if you don't like the cards you
wind up with you have the option to
redraw at least two of them each turn to
make sure you're never without options
your abilities come with a lot of
caveats and additional effects making
team Synergy and careful planning
extremely important for instance some
Attack cards come with the knockback
effect where the enemy you hit can be
sent flying if you crash them into an
object you can deal extra damage send
them into another character and you can
hurt both quick attacks give you an
extra card play in your turn if you you
kill the enemy you're attacking since
you can only play three cards in a turn
having quick cards can extend your
actions significantly you also need to
think about which enemies you target
since your cards will automatically move
your characters around the battlefield
which is sometimes essential to keeping
them out of Harm's Way from a coming
attack or effect but can also leave you
exposed if you're not careful playing
cards also builds up a resource called
heroism which is another key element of
your planning using your more powerful
cards requires you to spend heroism so
you want to build up your stock for
those big moments where you can do
things like Drive Ghost Rider's car
through multiple enemies or bombard the
battlefield with Iron Man's missiles but
you can also use heroism without cards
spending heroism can allow your
characters to interact with the
environment like throwing a rocket an
enemy or blowing up an explosive Barrel
if you've got enough heroism the
environment can give you what are
essentially additional attack
opportunities these special superpower
moves are unlocked by forging
relationships with other characters
while in your base of operations The
Abbey between the major plot points
midnight Suns allows you to explore
optional personal Side Stories and it's
in those smaller interactions between
the Hunter and the individual members of
their team that the game manages to
squeeze out memorable moments building
up your friendship with certain Heroes
unlocks additional cutscenes and
conversations with them many of which
culminate in heartwarming reveals or
devastating discoveries midnight Suns
tracks the flow of time in a way that's
similar to x-com limiting the actions
you can take during each in-game day at
the start of a day you wake up in the
Abbey where you can run around having
conversations with characters chasing
down Collectibles and advancing story
beats building up the base researching
new gear and interacting with a crafting
system that can earn you new cards at
some point you'll eventually pick combat
missions to take on the further in the
game you get like x-com the more
missions become available and you can
can choose to take on key Story battles
or go after more generic ones that offer
resources you might need after your
mission for the day you return to The
Abbey at night where more story unfolds
midnight Suns includes dialogue trees
that allow you to make choices about who
your Hunter is and how they react to
things and those choices can affect the
hunter standing with other characters
the game's creative director Jake
Solomon said your choices won't have big
effects on the overall narrative there
aren't multiple endings for instance but
they do affect your relationships with
the other characters and the dialogue
you might see from them the time you
spend on the story also has palpable
effects on the combat side of the game
Midnight Suns has an alignment system
for the hunter similar to what you might
see in a game like Mass Effect or
Fallout that ranges from light to dark
some dialogue responses fall into one of
the two categories adjusting your
alignment based on what you say and how
you treat people or situations but
alignment is also dictated by which
Hunter abilities you use light abilities
tend towards healing and support for
your teammates while dark abilities tend
towards dealing damage the more you use
light or dark abilities the more your
alignment shifts towards that end of the
spectrum allowing you to specialize the
hunter toward a specific combat role
while previous entries in the XCOM
series have included multiplayer
Marvel's midnight Suns is a single
player game for axis has assured fans
that it will not offer any
microtransactions that impact the
card-based battle system or gameplay in
any way there are no loot boxes and
you'll be unable to purchase the in-game
currency gamma coils to unlock more
cards you will be able to use real world
money to buy the other in-game currency
Eclipse credits but you can only use
those to buy cosmetic skins there will
be a season pass available for the game
that includes 23 premium skins as well
as four upcoming DLC Packs these pieces
of DLC each include a new hero missions
enemies skins and more the new heroes
are Deadpool X-Men's storm Venom and yes
morbius
morbin time after all midnight Suns will
launch for PC on both Steam and the epic
game store as well as on Xbox series X
and S and PlayStation 5 on December 2nd
the game is also coming to PS4 Xbox One
and even Nintendo switch but the release
date for those versions hasn't been
revealed yet there are four different
versions of midnight Suns and
pre-ordering any of them grants you the
doctor strange defender's skin first up
is the standard Edition for PC it'll
cost you 59.99 and includes the base
game which you'll get digitally then
there's the enhanced Edition for Xbox
series xns and PlayStation 5 which is
69.99 it's a physical copy of the game
that includes the base game five premium
skins as well as Xbox series and PS5
optimizations the digital plus edition
for Xbox series PS5 and PC is a digital
version of the game which includes the
base game with the next gen
optimizations as well as 11 premium
skins for 79.99 and finally there's the
legendary Edition which you can either
get in physical or digital form it
includes the base game and the season
pass which includes 23 premium skins
which you'll get at launch as well as
four pieces of DLC content which will
come at a later date if you pre-order
this Edition you get that Dr Strange
skin 30 days early and if you buy the
console version from a participating
GameStop store you'll get an Iron Man
Funko Pop the legendary edition is 99.99
for PC Xbox series and PS5 buying the
game's season pass gives you all the
content that you get in the legendary
edition we recently went Hands-On with
the game so to check out some more
gameplay as well as Jordan Remy's
Impressions make sure to click this
video and make sure to stay tuned to
Gamespot for our midnight Sun's review
which will be coming very soon thanks
for watching I'm on Twitter at Lucy
James games and I'll see you next time